hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2017 american science fiction movie
called the shape of water
the movie begins with elisa esposito a
mute woman who lives alone above a
cinema
she prepares herself and pays a visit to
her neighbor giles before going to work
afterwards elisa walks along the street
and takes a bus to occam aerospace
research center
she works as a janitor there with her
best friend zelda fuller
despite being mute alisa still can
understand and communicate with people
even zelda likes to talk to her during
their midnight shift mr fleming head of
security gathers all the staff and
introduces the new researcher dr robert
hofstedler to them
suddenly a vessel which contains a very
valuable asset is brought to the
facility and colonel richard strickland
is assigned to supervise the study of
the asset alisa goes near the vessel and
suddenly a creature bumps against the
glass
in the morning giles takes elisa to his
favorite pie shop where giles seems to
have a crush with the waiter he always
tries to bring up a topic to keep the
conversation going
they return home and alisa does not like
the pie
giles apparently doesn't eat the pie too
and stores all of them in the fridge
while the janitors are cleaning the
bathroom colonel richard comes in and
puts his taser on a wash bin before
urinating
after he leaves alisa spots a blood
stain on the wash basin
not long after elisa and zelda hear a
scream coming from a room and richard
suddenly comes out with his fingers
missing from his left hand
the ladies are ordered to clean the mess
in the laboratory where elise
accidentally finds richard's missing
fingers coming out under the shelf
when zelda is away alisa approaches an
aquarium in the asset which turns out to
be a fish-like humanoid creature emerges
from inside
she then gives the body parts to fleming
meanwhile giles works as a designer for
an advertising company and they want him
to make a new poster for a product
the next evening alisa goes to work as
usual and sneaks into the laboratory to
interact with the creature
she feeds it with boiled eggs and is
fascinated by its beauty as she leaves
the room she meets zelda who tells her
that richard wants to see them both
colonel richard interrogates them asking
several questions about their background
zelda reveals to him that elisa was
found by the river when she was a baby
and has been mute since childhood before
he dismisses them richard warns them to
keep their mouths shut about the
creature in the laboratory the following
day richard goes home and it is revealed
that richard and his family just moved
to america for some reason alisa is very
happy when she is assigned to clean up
the laboratory where the creature is
being kept
that day she brings more eggs to feed
the creature and even sneaks a music
player
elisa teaches the creature sign language
and it seems like they understand each
other she frequently comes to the
laboratory and dances in front of the
creature
unfortunately this encounter is seen by
dr robert
the next day dr robert who is actually a
russian spy named dimitri meets up with
his boss
they head over to a restaurant to
discuss the further action that needs to
be done towards the asset he reports his
findings to the boss informing him that
the creature is intelligent and is able
to communicate with humans back to elisa
she sneaks into the laboratory as usual
to meet the creature she accidentally
falls down and drops an egg
soon after she hears someone is coming
and decides to hide
at the same time richard comes in and
tortures the creature with his taser
he subsequently finds the egg that
belongs to elisa
that night general hoyt arrives at the
facility and tells the room about
america's rivalry with the soviet in the
space race
colonel richard suggests they harvest
the creature's body to enhance their
space traveling technology as it has a
unique lung structure that allow the
creature to breath in both water and
ground
dr robert forbids them to kill the
creature but the general doesn't care
and leaves
alisa who has been eavesdropping the
entire conversations becomes fearful for
the creature's safety
she tells giles that she wants to get it
out of the facility but he doesn't agree
with the plan because it's just an
experimental creature
alisa insists as it's the first time
somebody accepts her for what she is and
doesn't see her deficiency as a problem
giles leaves her and refuses to help her
he meets his boss and shows him the art
but the boss rejects the masterpiece
leaving giles in disappointment giles
then goes to the pie shop and at some
point he tries to hold the waiter's hand
however the man becomes angry and
forbids him to come to the pie shop
again
on the other hand dr robert rendezvous
is with his boss again who gives him a
poison to kill the creature to prevent
the americans from advancing their
scientific developments the scientist
seems to disagree with the plan but he
has to obey the order left with no one
giles returns to alisa and agrees to
help her in the evening elisa explores
the facility to find a way out for the
creature while giles will be waiting for
her outside
back to richard he seems to have a crush
on alisa and often observes her from the
surveillance camera
he deliberately spills the water and
calls the janitor to his room
richard then sexually harasses her
making elisa terrified and leaves
meanwhile dr robert prepares the syringe
in the bathroom and elisa begins the
extraction plan
she turns the surveillance camera away
from her escape route
at the same time dr robert changes his
mind and protests to colonel richard
that they should postpone the procedure
to kill the creature while doing so he
accidentally spots the camera being
moved by someone a few moments later
alisa attempts to rescue the creature
while dr robert suddenly confronts her
surprisingly he decides to help her
because he still wants to study the
creature and elisa sneaks the asset in a
laundry hamper to buy her some time dr
robert plants an explosive that kills
all the electricity in the facility
at the loading dock zelda initially
interrupts elisa but then decides to
help her as they are running out of time
they get the asset inside the van and
giles drives them all away while
wrecking richard's brand new car in the
process
simultaneously colonel richard becomes
suspicious with the van and the loading
dock and goes after them but it is too
late
they transport the creature to giles's
house and she puts it inside her bathtub
pouring several chemicals and salt to
maintain the water's condition
she is planning on releasing the
creature in a canal to prevent it being
captured by richard again
meanwhile richard discovers an israeli
explosive thinking that the asset was
stolen by russian
when she goes to the facility the
following night richard once again
questions zelda and alisa
after claiming that they saw nothing
richard dismisses them as she leaves
elisa signs the f words to richard but
zelda translates it as thank you when
giles is asleep the creature steps out
of the bathroom and eats one of his cats
giles tries to stop him but the creature
is frightened by him and runs away while
accidentally scratches his arm in the
process
alisa returns home and is shocked when
she finds giles bleeding
she searches for the asset only to find
it in the cinema beneath her apartments
alisa brings it upstairs where the
creature approaches giles and touches
his arm and head magically curing his
scratch wounds
alisa and the creature become closer and
closer
they even make love in the bathroom
afterwards she goes to work and tells
zelda about the experience of having fun
with a non-human
on the other hand dr robert is visited
by his boss who believes that the asset
has been killed he almost intends to
kill him if things go wrong but turns
out that the boss still believes in his
words
one day elisa deliberately floods the
bathroom creating a small pool so that
they both can swim and have fun together
however this action causes a leak into
the cinema
giles is informed about the water leaks
by the furious cinema's owner so he
comes into elise's room and opens the
bathroom's door
subsequently giles is very happy when he
discovers his hair is growing again and
the wound is fully cured after being
touched by the creature
at the facility general hoyt suddenly
pays a visit and gives colonel richard
36 hours to find the missing asset
he threatens richard that his career
will be over as soon as he finds the
creature alisa realizes that that day is
the day she will release the creature
but she is already too attached to it
she even imagines a scenario where she
dances with the creature and sings
several love songs to it
zelda comes over and sees that the
creature is dying because they already
lack the chemicals
still that evening dr robert meets his
boss to discuss his extrication from the
facility
however the boss figures out that it is
still alive and shoots him
richard who has been following dr robert
appears and shoots the russian boss
he then grabs the scientist and tortures
him until he spills out the asset's
location
the colonel immediately heads over to
zelda's house but finds nothing zelda
doesn't reveal the location and richard
goes crazy tearing off his two fingers
that still haven't completely healed
soon after the husband brewster tells
richard that elisa took the creature
the colonel thanks him and goes after
the mute girl
zelda then calls elisa to warn her as
richard arrives the asset has been
brought away but he finds a note on a
calendar and learns that they are taking
it to the canal
alisa and giles drive away to the canal
where they say their last goodbye to the
creature the asset responds that elisa
and him belong together but elisa states
that it must go without her afterwards
the colonel shows up and punches giles
just before shooting both elisa and the
creature
giles then grabs a wood beam and hits
richard with it thanks to its
self-healing ability the creature
revives itself and confronts the colonel
killing him instantly with its claws
as the police arrive the creature takes
elisa underwater where it resurrects her
by kissing her it also turns the scars
on her neck into gills allowing her to
breathe in the water
since then alisa has found her true love
and they both live happily after
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching